-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-You look fantastic.
I love you.
I always love having you
on the show
or doing anything with you.
-Me, too.
-Officially right now,
"Familia" is out.
It is available.
You can download it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can download it,
you can buy it,
go to stores,
go to record shops, wherever.
Play it. Play it loud.
-Do it all!
It's out.
Do it all!
Familia!
-[ Screams ]
-Yes!
How does it feel?
-It feels -- I feel like you
saying that right now,
I'm really trying
to take it in, you know?
-Yeah, of course.
-I'm taking it the...in
-Yeah, grounded.
You ground it.
You're taking it in,
and you're going...
-I'm taking it in.
No, because I feel like
because I've been going,
going, going.
-Yeah.
-It's important to have
those moments where you're like,
"Wow, this album
that it was a two-year
journey for me
and this album
and the journey of it
was really life changing for me.
I feel like I learned
the most I've ever learned.
Like it was --
-In your entire life.
-Yeah, totally.
I really changed as a person.
And long story short, like,
I think like in the beginning
was I started this album,
what was a really like
low mental health period for me.
And I only really --
I only wanted to go back
in the studio and work
if it felt like something
that helped me on my journey
to feeling better
and was a source of joy
and healing and fun.
And I did it completely
different
than I've ever written
any other one before.
I was a really,
really small group of people.
It started with me
and my friend Scott
in like my home, like house,
bedroom in Miami.
-Just working on stuff.
-Just like talking
about anxiety, basically.
-Yeah.
-I think the difference between
me now and me before
was I think in the --
in the writing process,
sometimes I just felt like
I had a lot to prove.
Like I was just like,
I want people, you know,
I want this person to think
I'm a good songwriter,
I want whatever, whatever.
And also I think my own battles
with like with anxiety
and mental health stuff.
I was young
and I felt a lot of shame
in talking about it,
I felt like I had to go
and just like have it
all together
and be this kind of, like,
confident, you know,
"pop star" that just --
And on the inside,
I was just like,
you know,
like really struggling.
And this time around,
I was like, you know what?
I'm not trying to prove
anything to anybody.
I'm not trying
to impress anybody.
I'm just trying to be me,
be vulnerable,
make songs
that are really just like,
just be [bleep] honest.
Sorry for swearing.
-Yeah, go for it.
I know.
I love it, you know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's exactly what we want.
-Yeah.
And -- and I think
in doing that,
I really -- there's like --
I said this on my album
thank you's.
I was like, you know,
before I felt like
I needed to be kind of healed
or perfect to be seen,
and I realized that being seen
is what kind of
is the healing thing, you know?
-Yeah.
-And so that's why
it's called "Familia."
I started by saying
long story short.
It's actually long story long.
-[ Laughs ]
It's actually, no,
it's a great story.
But I also -- I mean, there are
some good criers on here,
but it's a lot of dance on here.
-Totally.
-You're making people have fun.
I mean, this is --
this is a journey.
This is like -- it's everything.
-For me, also why I name
the album "Familia,"
for me, it was like
that support group
that I made, my collaborators,
my friends, my family,
my therapist, like whatever,
like opening up to people.
That kind of interdependence
and like leaning on other people
is something that has
been a big,
has been defining,
like, word for this chapter
is like interdependence,
you know?
Like -- and because
we always talk about,
I feel like especially
culturally, like independence
and I did this
on my own and I whatever.
And to me,
this is about celebrating
the people in my life,
you know, my -- my family.
This is my little cousin, Caro.
And...
-I know. She's so cute.
-She's very cute.
-I mean, come on.
-She's on the album.
She sings on the album.
My dad sings on the album.
-I mean, I love that.
Also, did Caro freestyle rap?
-I like how you say her name.
You say her name like car,
like Caro.
-Caro.
-Yeah.
-No,
-So that's car.
-Okay.
-And then...
-And what is her name?
-And then there's Caro,
like Carolina.
It's like a little.
-Caro.
-It's a subtle difference.
-Yeah, there we go.
-Caro.
-I like it.
She's not old enough to drive.
-She's not a car.
-No?
-No, no, no.
-When she's nueva...
-Diec--
-[ Speaks Spanish ]
-Dieciséis, dieciséis.
-Dieciséis.
-Yes.
-She can drive a car.
But unfortunately, Caro...
-Caro, yeah.
-...can't drive a car.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-That track on here?
No, it's not on here.
But you brought us an exclusive
audio of her freestyle.
How old?
-Okay, so she was eight
when she basically...
So my dad came to the studio.
We had like a whole mariachi
set up there and he freestyled,
and then she came over.
And on this song "Celia"
that I have, we were like,
Caro, it was me,
her and my producer, Ricky.
And she's just like,
freestyle the thing.
-Not to hate there, but it's
actually [thrills] Ricky.
-Exactly, sorry.
-It's okay, no big deal.
It's okay.
-Oh, my God. I'm so embarrassed.
-He's not watching, but -- but
you brought this clip.
You want to hear it.
Listen to this.
Take a listen.
This is Caro.
-[ Singing in Spanish ]
♪♪
-Okay, so she said now I live
in Miami.
Now I have eight years old.
♪ I also have a dog ♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I also have a dog ♪
-♪ Dog ♪
-I want to talk
about "Saturday Night Live."
I want to talk about
what songs you might do,
but I just want to hear
about everything, okay?
When we come back,
more with Camila Cabello.